une histoire qu'on voulait mettre au
clair il ya une rumeur qui a enflé avec
moi je n en doute et les fans sont comme
sur cette rumeur que le seuil des noms
mais il faut dire que vous a vu faire
des vidéos ensemble elle était même chez
toi qu'est ce qui se passe avec quoi on
en est ou qui se passe avec les jeux ds
de la saison voilà donc 18 ans 16 ans ça
passerait à ses lectrices et les adultes
ça y est miller alors qu'est-ce qui se
passe il se passe rien c'est juste ont
fait début en fait c'est comme on est
souvent les gens nous voient souvent
ensemble et il centro s'imaginer des
couples et toi moi je me bat jill aussi
aux plaignants on s'imagine tout y'a
aucun délit n'a rien rien on n'a rien
quoi je n'aime rien aussi enjoué
d'adacore donc à personne la personne au
tamis mois et personne dans ma vie moi
je t'aime aussi mais là c'est à dire que
les deux personnes dont j'aimais en
jouit
michou et wyden ses forêts voilà on
l'embrassé
tu vois lui vient petit à petit bisou je
vois que je vais voir si un dos ou pas
si j'avais des grands bisous
non non on a le meilleur régime et non à
ben c'est vrai j'ai fait comme ça c'est
combien
[Applaudissements]